à voir ses baguettes brioches et
pâtisseries qui donne l'eau à la bouche
on a du mal à croire qu'elles sont les
oeuvres d'apprentis n'ayant que six
semaines d'expérience et pourtant voilà
le résultat du travail des huit
stagiaires du tout nouveau centre de
formation cuisine mode d'emploi de dijon
un cursus au pas de charge
où l'on considère qu'il faut faire pour
apprendre la pratique avant tout un
programme qui séduit nos futurs
boulangers c'est intensif
et ça c'est sympa de d'apprendre comme
ça
plutôt que faire des cures directement
des pratiques c'est pour ça que j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'on fait en ce moment quoi
parce qu'on apprend vraiment tous les
jours des choses différentes que ce soit
en pâtisserie lointain c'est vrai qu'on
apprend différentes choses et c'est
super intéressant c'est le chef étoilé
thierry marx qui a imposé ce rythme de
12 semaines dans les différents centres
de formation qu'il a ouverts sur le
territoire ce rythme des douze semaines
il est très important pour se rendre
compte de ce concept de ce qu'est la
réalité de ce métier
si vous n'arrivez pas à vous lever le
matin ça est très compliqué de faire ce
métier si vous vous faites trois
croissants à l'heure ça va être très
compliqué là aussi donc il faut mieux
s'en rendront très tôt il faut pas
attendre deux ans pour se rendre compte
que votre parquet pour ce métier de
notre côté on est certain que nos
apprentis sont bien fait pour ce métier
ancien demandeur d'emploi de longue
durée bénéficiaires du rsa ou encore
jeunes sans qualification au moment de
l'inauguration il était ému et fier du
travail accompli
d'avoir fait quelque chose déjà qu'il me
plaît mon produit me plaît le produit
que nous avons réalisés me plaît
de pouvoir nous montrer aux gens de
leur apprendre ce qu'on a fait
c'est vrai que j'éprouve une certaine
fierté comme il ne reste que deux
semaines de cours aux stagiaires et
trois semaines en entreprise avant la
fin de leur cursus 90 % des apprentis
qui sortent de ces formations cuisine
mode d'emploi ont trouvé un travail